[Musique]
la fresque du climat en fait c'est un
atelier qui est ludique et qui est
collaboratif il consiste à simplement en
trois heures à jouer aux cartes pour
essayer de comprendre les causes et les
conséquences d'un phénomène qui nous
touche tous et toutes qui est le
dérèglement climatique
peut lire les rapports du GIEC ces 3000
pages c'est compliqué personne ne lui en
entier et en fait là avec une sorte de
jeu très instructif très plaisant on
arrive à avoir quand même une synthèse
des vrais codescences actuelles celle
qui ne sont pas discutées au niveau
scientifique
l'objet c'est de prendre en compte les
conséquences inéluctables et
incontestables du réchauffement
climatique les collectivités locales
quel que soit leur taille sont
concernées par ces conséquences et donc
la mission de la délégation c'est
d'aller au plus près de la réalité du
terrain et donc nous allons prendre en
compte l'ensemble de cette réflexion
auprès des auditions qu'il nous reste à
mener avant la fin de notre mission
comment les élus vont mettre en place
cette transition environnementale
comment y arriver que ce soit le coma
parce que quelque chose qui est
tellement vaste et ce comment là nous
voulons faire une sorte non pas de
cahier de préconisations mais au moins
de bonne pratique qui puisse être
reproductive c'est une mission
extrêmement concrète qui aujourd'hui
nous donne l'occasion de noter encore
une fois combien les collectivités
locales sont réactives
si on ne prend pas les bonnes décisions
très rapidement à l'échelle mondiale
nous aurons des conséquences qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à des guerres voir jusqu'à
des sécheresses voir des inondations de
plus en plus importantes cette phrase
qu'on l'a fait pas tout seul comme on
lit un rapport on l'a fait ensemble et
c'est aussi ensemble qu'on peut beaucoup
mieux agir sur ces questions